На цьому відео Байрактар накриває колону ворожого війська і знищує російський БУК
в районі Малина Житомирської області.
А тут - український бойовий дрон R18 палить російську військову техніку
на східному напрямку фронту - танки і КАМАЗи.
Таких знищених цілей на рахунку Збройних сил України - вже сотні.
А допомагають у цьому - безпілотники.
Дуже багато броньованої техніки, БТРи, багато танків російських, причому різних танків
- і більш старих моделей, і більш нових. Навіть був випадок, коли знищили станцію РЕБ одну російську.
Багато складів з боєприпасами, коли знешкоджували нашими дронами.
Ударні дрони можуть зависати над ціллю і дуже точно вражати броньовану техніку.
Та головне - будь-який дрон допомагає зберегти життя військових.
Для розвідки тепер не треба повзти на пузі кілометр по полю і підставлятися
під вогонь кулеметів та автоматів із ворожих окопів.
Можна підняти дрона, побачити все, що тобі потрібно.
Мало того, ще можна це записати на відео, принести у штаб, де можуть побачити ще більше,
аніж ти побачив на самому екрані телефона під час розвідувального вильоту.
Масово та ефективно в Україні почали застосовувати дрони з початку війни у 2014 році.
Тоді це були комерційні безпілотники, які літали на 1-2 кілометри.
Та це дало поштовх для створення українських компаній, які виробляють різні види
безпілотних апаратів - для повітряної розвідки, контролю над переміщенням противника,
коригування вогню артилерії та бойового застосування.
У нас з 2014-го року народилися такі компанії, як Укрспецсистемс,
яка виробляє лінійку безпілотних апаратів PD-1, PD-2;
компанія DEVIRO, яка виробляє комплекс Лелека-100, який вже модифіковувався декілька разів
і зараз виробляється напевно одна з найкращих його моделей;
компанія "Атлон Авіа", яка виробляє комплекс "Фурія".
Є також безпілотні комплекси Spectator та багато інших.
Який дрон застосовують військові - залежить від їхніх завдань.
Для рівня роти батальйону - підійде звичайний квадрокоптер комерційного виробництва
із денною тепловізійною зумованою камерою. Такі ж військового зразка, наприклад,
латвійські безпілотні комплекси Atlas Aerospace. Вони стають очима бійців на полі бою.
Зараз їх здебільшого забезпечують волонтерські організації.
А от для бригади батальйону - потрібні розвідувальники-коригувальники,
як от "Фурія" чи "Лелека". Швидко закупити багато таких дронів для держави - важко.
Тож поки тривають бюрократичні процеси - волонтери закривають прогалини.
До прикладу, ми законтрактували 25 комплексів "Лелека-100", інші фонди - 10, 5,
а держава тільки їх починає контрактувати. Ми їх підстраховуємо.
Але держава зараз, у свою чергу, виходить на історію про контракти 100 комплексів і більше.
І ці літаки на бригадному рівні з радіусом роботи приблизно 35-45 кілометрів.
Тобто це глибина роботи бригадно-артилерійської групи.
А от безпілотники стратегічного застосування летять від 80 до 200 кілометрів,
знаходять цілі і коригують вогонь озброєння, наприклад "Хаймарсів" чи "Нептунів".
Це українські PD-2 чи турецькі "Байрактари".
Himars знищили за останні два тижні 30 надзвичайно важливих цілей противника,
таких як командні пукти і склади з боєприпасами, порушили логістику противника.
І ми очевидно бачимо зараз на полі бою, на фронті суттєве зниження інтенсивності
атак противника, атак росіян. Це означає, що те, що наносяться удари, - ефективно.
Але для того, щоби ці удари були ефективними, система розвідки добувала координати.
У військово-морських силах "Байрактари" часто використовуються саме як розвідувальна система.
Бо наведення тих же "Гарпунів" і "Нептунів" на ціль здійснюється якраз "Байрактарами".
Знищення ракетного крейсера "Москва" відбувалося так, що "Байрактари"
визначали координати цілі, тобто ракетного крейсера, передавали цю інформацію
на "Нептуни", і "Нептуни" вже знищували його за рішенням командування.
Звичайні безпілотники під час війни - це справжній розхідний матеріал.
Та воювати без них - неможливо.
Так, дрони досить дорогі. Деякі з них коштують від 80-ти тисяч,
а з тепловізором вони коштують четверть мільйона.
І ми подібних дронів з 24-го лютого, здається, купили більше 3,5 тисяч.
Це неймовірна сума коштів. Це сотні мільйонів гривень. Але ми розуміємо, що не маючи дрона,
підрозділ має повні шанси загинути. Тому що він не бачить, хто проти нього воює,
яка кількість, які в нього плани, задуми, як він пересувається і тому подібне.
Він просто елементарно не може побачити наступ.
Постійна потреба військових у дронах - це тисячі одиниць різних видів.
Щоб побудувати високотехнологічну армію за стандартами НАТО, яка зможе вести бойові дії
з мінімальними втратами - запровадили ініціативу "Армія дронів".
Проєкт започаткований Міністерством цифрової трансформації,
Генштабом Збройних сил України, платформою United24 та Держспецзв`язку.
Кожен охочий може переказати кошти на закупівлю дронів чи пожертвувати власний безпілотник.
За два тижні вже вдалося зібрати 400 мільйонів гривень.
В першу чергу ми закуповуємо дрони-розвідники. Це дрони, які можуть літати
від двох до 60, до 100 кілометрів, професійні, військові дрони за стандартами НАТО.
І в нас вже є перший контракт, ми підписуємо їх придбання з польською стороною.
Перший етап - це закупівля 200 таких дронів з усього світу.
Крім того, ми потребуємо звичайних цивільних дронів. Їх потрібно тисячі.
І окрема категорія - це дрони-камікадзе, дрони, які нищать ворога.
Роль дронів під час війни Росії проти України - критично важлива.
Їхнє застосування дає можливість віддалено вести розвідку,
виявляти ворожі сили і техніку, коригувати вогонь артилерії чи самостійно наносити удари.
І в цьому Україна набагато випереджає Росію.